[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I see girl I think you human
but you ape like me they'll put down how
long have you been here hmm
are there more like you more Apes from
Zoo yet hold it long time human get sick
it get smart then human kill it but not
me
I thought you learn to speak listen
human
bad ape
[Music]
no no touch that that's mine eat new
friends special day yeah
you can't keep
where did you get this bad place humans
ooh that human that humans soldiers
soldier can you take us humans ooh no no
no go back there very safe here never go
back look look look look more snow
can I go mistake
oh yes child
I don't know but she was you
he has no one else we are not savages
apes fight only to survive bad human
kill 8o all dead now a long time
Oh time bad humans soldier
years from now your children will ask
you what did you do in the greatest war
and you can tell them I fought to
protect this world
we created them but now
we will bring it in to their kind
no mercy no peace this this war
names together sleep
you are impressive smart as hell you're
stronger than we are that you're taking
this all much too personally so
emotional
I did not start this war
but I will finish it
[Music]
[Music]
Oh